Time magazine's Person of the Year you
know they announce that all the time
this is very cool Time magazine's Person
of the Year is 16 year old climate
activists Creta toon burg yeah yeah
after being told the 16 year old girl
asked what's a magazine just no idea I'm
starting to forget what am I grew up
with them and I'm starting to forget
what they are those things at the
dentists yeah exactly yeah Rudy Giuliani
is now officially divorced yeah
in response today thousands of women
deactivated their tinder profile hey
here many are going off the grid yeah
yeah and they're burying their phones
it's come out that Harvey Weinstein
who's out on bail tried to remove his
ankle bracelet at least 50 times yeah
Weinstein said you have no idea what it
feels like to have something on you
without your consent
[Applause]
yes yes you're on the right side of that
issue brave of you to be against Harvey
Weinstein yeah the University of Phoenix
has agreed to cancel a hundred and
forty-one million dollars in student
debt yeah yeah the Dean said it's enough
of a burden that these kids have to say
I'm a graduate of the University of
Phoenix that's enough why should it be
more the best university